it's a busy news day more of our top
story tonight a first look at the man
accusing a shooting that happened on a
Northeast Valley Middle School campus
Metro Police say 18-year-old Jesse Rios
was shooting a gun from a car Monday
when a stray bullet hit a campus
security monitor now Rios is now facing
24 felony charges including attempted
murder today though still a lot of
unanswered questions as to why there
were 19 gunshots fired near the Middle
School 8 news now reporter Ryan Matthey
joins us live from ventoble middle
school with the latest on this case
yeah Denise as of now Metro Police
describes the shooting more as a
coincidence than a actual targeted
attack and what they suspect right now A
group of teenagers from their car set
off the gunfire headed straight towards
the school campus here it's left the
school Community questioning what
exactly happened and could this have
been avoided
I'm pretty nervous about today because I
don't know what could happen with
students from 11 to 14 years old
returning to campus Tuesday morning
after being locked down Monday afternoon
it was like 30 minutes until the school
day ended the the cops came in I got
stuck in the hallway so I had to wait
for them to open the door for like a
little while Monday afternoon police
responded to the school around 12 30.
Tuesday morning they announced the
initial shots were seemingly from blocks
away a stray bullet from an unrelated
incident striking an unidentified campus
security monitor employed through CCSD
police identified the shooter as 18 year
old Jesse Rios booked into Clark County
Detention Tuesday Morning the court
records show he faces four attempted
murder charges a battery with a deadly
weapon cow and 19 counts of discharging
a gun into an occupied structure just
say all was a straight bullet that would
be the wrong way to look at this though
not a school shooting but rather a
shooting near a school parents are still
on edge Troy Martinez has created dads
in school to deploy adult Patrol
volunteers to campuses he says no
parents from this school have signed up
could this be something you could Patrol
out of if there is an intentional act
and they see a grown man in uniform it
is a potential deterrent because these
are cowards that bring this type of
violence on children
but there are still some other
unanswered questions we asked Metro
Police like what were the circumstances
of the gunfire how did it travel so far
where exactly was that campus monitor on
campus during the shooting and how did
they find the suspect and get him into
custody we're still awaiting those
answers reporting live outside vonto
Middle School Brian mathie 8 News Now